it is great to welcome back to the
program today dr isaac bogash who's an
infectious disease physician and
scientist based out of the university of
toronto and toronto general hospital
uh always great to talk to you
all nice to see you again so i guess
just to start with briefly
um we're seeing the u.s number of
coronavirus cases
down from their sort of second peak
still around 40 000 cases a day i know
you're in canada i don't know how
closely you're following the ins and
outs of case numbers here
but there's some skepticism about
whether these case numbers
can be trusted at this point given a lot
of different things that have gone on
with the data with testing pause due to
weather events and so many other things
my question to you is is there really a
better metric to pay attention to
at this point be it hospitalizations or
deaths or something else in all fairness
i look at a combination of metrics i
think the number of new cases per day is
very very helpful but above and beyond
that i look at other metrics as well i
look at the seven day average i look at
the number of tests that are performed i
look at the
percentage of tests that are positive
out of the number of tests that are
performed
and i really think that when we sort of
combine all of those metrics and more we
really paint a more holistic picture
that gives us a better understanding
of course if testing isn't being done
it's hard to know exactly
what the ground truth is but in all
fairness i think it's
by this point in time we sort of know in
most
regions how things are going and what
direction things are turning
either for better or for worse so one
specific question on testing and
positivity
sometimes we will see a situation where
it looks like
in a particular state cases have gone
down
and then when you look in a little more
detail you see
that tests are down 30
and new cases are only down 10
which implies a higher positivity rate
and it suggests that it's because
you're doing less testing that cases
have gone down the counterpoint is well
you know if the testing goes down you're
probably only testing sicker people
so it makes sense that the positivity
rate would go up
it doesn't necessarily mean there are
actually more cases out there
is there any way to know for sure well
yes there is and the real answer is
getting
lots of disparate data sources together
in one place and really that is why it
is so important
to look at several metrics rather than
just relying
on a handful of metrics and then of
course watching the metrics through time
an individual day or even a few days
really does nothing to us it's really
important to look
at longer term trends seven day trends
and and beyond
uh and i think if we're starting to do
that and stop reacting to you know
terms like uptick and downtick every
time we see some
variation in the data will be in a much
better place there's going to be the
expected
normal variations on a day-to-day basis
and even maybe on a bit of a longer term
basis
but if we look at weekly trends and look
at multiple data sources
i think we'll be in the right place and
really truly all of those combined
together give us
gives us a good impression i don't think
anyone following this is really looking
at
that you know one true metric that's
really going to provide all the answers
it's a it's a multitude of metrics so
let's talk about the next
three to four months um
some of the countries that did
successfully flatten their curves
are starting to see some more cases
spain is one example that i've been
looking at and there are many others
in the united states when we first got
down to 20 000 cases a day
things just basically reopened and we
went all the way way back up to 75 now
we're back down to 40.
what is the best assessment now of what
was originally thought of in the
may projections to be a discrete second
wave which now is just
maybe going to be a kind of continuation
what is the timing looking like how bad
could it potentially get
it's interesting because we talk about
the second wave like it has some finite
definition
and in all fairness i don't think it
really matters whether or not this is a
spike in the first wave a plateau in the
first wave a distinct second wave
i think a lot of this is irrelevant in
the sense that number one you still have
a very susceptible population meaning
that
you know in most places the vast
majority of people have not
had this infection so are susceptible to
getting this infection
and number two if you don't have
controls in place to keep this infection
at bay
uh you're going to see widespread
transmission
so you know if we look in the crystal
ball a lot
there's you know it it we can predict
what's going to happen
if people are in indoor environments in
close proximity
for prolonged periods of time we know
that this is the perfect setup for
transmission now let's think about
what's going to happen
in the months ahead at least in the
northern parts of the united states
it's going to get cool we've got kids
going back to school
we've got many people going back to work
in person we've got cooler temperatures
that are driving us inside
we've got economies that are opening and
all of those
just put people together in indoor
environments for prolonged periods of
time
that is where this virus is transmitted
if we take steps to mitigate that
spread people apart put a mask on when
you go inside
limit the number of people in indoor
settings we can probably do a decent job
in mitigating the spread
but i still think we'll probably see a
rise in cases at least in the northern
part of the united states
and certainly in canada as we enter the
fall and winter months
so in terms of masks obviously
there's been a lot about masks over the
last many months
in particular there is disagreement i
guess we can say about
the degree to which masks prevent
transmission and whether they're really
to protect one from spreading versus to
protect one from catching
or both there's a very popular meme
that's been floating around which assert
you know it puts numbers to it where it
says
both people wear a mask it's like a one
percent chance of transmission
if one person wears a mask it mask it's
five percent if neither one does it's
fit or whatever right
yeah i'm sure those aren't the right
numbers but
are there any numbers or or specificity
to
the effect of masks and then of course
what type of mask i'm guessing is a
factor as well
right i think we can talk about this in
general principles and
and you know i certainly just full
disclosure
mask is probably my least favorite topic
of this epidemic or pandemic
interesting for whatever reason this was
like the hot button issue
this was politicized to such a degree
people have very very strong opinions
on on many different sides of the
equation people are cherry-picking data
to suit their preconceived ideas
and it's really frustrating when you
really want to just take a
public health look at this an
epidemiologic look at it
a medical and scientific look at it it's
kind of frustrating and and quite
frankly it's frustrating because
people who should know better are are
still
i think speaking beyond the data or
still cherry-picking data having said
that there are
many rational voices both in the lake
community and them and in the medical
scientific and public health community
and i commend those people because
anytime we talk about this for whatever
reason there seems to be a dog pile
effect
now let's get to the question so in
general
based on what we know now we can talk
about math
at an individual level and we can also
talk about masks at a population level
i think we can also talk about mass in a
healthcare specific area
as well but in general at an individual
level if you put a mask on
and you're infected you're just going to
reduce the amount of virus that you
transmit to the environment around you
seems to make sense pretty good idea now
does this pan out
at a population level um
it's interesting there's modeling
studies which
quite frankly you know i work in
epidemiology as well
and you know a lot of my career is based
on
working with modeling and and and
whatnot i i've got to say like
i should be the big supporter of models
i think models are helpful
but i don't think they really answer
definitively
the questions that we want to answer
they're helpful
they're useful but we have to take a lot
of the modeling data with a grain of
salt
so at an individual level great i think
it's it's a no-brainer
we've known this long before covet 19.
if you put on a mask you just
reduce the amount of virus you're going
to shed in the environment around you
at a population level the waters get a
bit
murkier will it really help
at a population level if there's masking
yeah you know what at the end of the day
if we sift through the data
it probably helps but i think it helps
to a much smaller extent
than what many people might believe or
might want to believe
but i'm not saying it doesn't help i
think it does
and then you know how do you take this
data and translate into policy
i think at the end of the day we also
know where this virus is transmitted
it's almost
well i shouldn't say exclusively but
it's truly an
indoor virus like there's just
remarkably few transmissions
of this virus that are incredible uh
that have been documented in outdoor
settings sure can happen in an outdoor
setting but it's just
not nearly as common as indoor setting
so if
we take our data that we have with mass
with the
total appreciation that this is
imperfect data with the total
appreciation that it's going to be
impossible to
you know at this point to have a perfect
randomized double-blind
placebo-controlled trial or whatever we
want to
design you know but if we take the
existing data that we have i think it's
very reasonable to translate that into
policy to say listen
if you're in an indoor setting you
should put on a mask
i think it's as simple as that outdoors
i'm i mean i i've seen
some of the narratives coming out of the
united states with people saying you
know i went for a
20k jog and i had a mask on my whole
time and this didn't
didn't bother me one bit you know mazel
tov we're all very proud of you for
wearing a mask but like i don't think
you're at
risk of transmitting this infection if
you're on a 20k jogging you probably
don't need to wear a mat
i'd focus on indoor settings i think
masks are a great idea
taking the politics out of it we should
be putting on a mask when we go indoors
yeah i mean i i i've said this we don't
let's we'll move on after this but
here in boston now if you're just even
walking downtown if you don't have a
mask on
you know people can kind of look at you
from the studies i've looked at
it really doesn't seem like that is at
all a high risk scenario but if people
want to do it like you said mazel tov
you know like i am i'll do it i'll do it
in order to participate because i don't
want to be the person who's not
participating but it doesn't really seem
to be based too much in the science
i think you have a really good point
there and a lot of this
bleeds well out of science
and medicine and into more sociological
or socio-political conversation
i'm sitting here in toronto i cannot
comment
i cannot emphasize on what you're going
through in the united states in terms of
the degree of politicization
that this has had and if the mask might
also represent
a lot more than hey i'm
i'm here to keep you safe in case i'm
infected and i appreciate that there's a
lot more going on in the united states
with regards to that than there is in
canada
it might be a signal that i align with
this particular group or that i have
these particular beliefs
and in all fairness i'm not into shaming
and blaming people want to wear a mask
go for it wear a mask but like where i
would be more of a stickler about it
is in indoor settings i think it's
important that people put them on when
they go inside
i think that will actually have some
utility in preventing the transmission
of this infection
okay so vaccines multiple vaccine
candidates
um on spec production of a number of
them
so that if indeed we learn this one is a
go or that one is a go
doses will be available makes perfect
sense
russia claims to have a vaccine which
has a number of questions around it
at this point my thought has been
the optimistic scenario is somewhere
around october 15
there's an announcement made that a
vaccine
is safe and at least gives four or five
months of immunity
it starts to be rolled out slowly
healthcare workers
maybe by the end of the year 2021
high high-risk populations uh is that
still the optimistic scenario
where where are we on vaccines yeah i
mean the pace of vaccine development is
just staggering this is phenomenal
there's
uh about two dozen that are in human
clinical trials remember
we didn't know this infection existed
seven months ago
and now seven months in you've got just
over two dozen in human clinical trials
i think right now there's
six or seven that are in what's called
phase three human clinical studies like
that's amazing i mean that's that's
where you're enrolling thousands and
thousands and thousands of people to
answer the question
does it work and is it safe so you know
there's tremendous pace and of course we
know many of these vaccines are going to
fail
but there's so many that are in
development and even in advanced stages
of development that
i'm with you i i do share that
optimistic outlook that will probably
have
some successful trials in before the end
of 2020
i wouldn't be surprised if needles start
going in arms before the end of 2020.
hey i could be totally wrong i could be
way off and it could be
2021 and these might be a bust but the
looking at the data that we have
available to us it's pretty promising
it's not you know nothing of course is
guaranteed but i share that i share that
view
um i also like that concept where uh
many governments or i guess in in
in partnership with the companies just
say you know what let's just mass
produce
these vaccines now we appreciate that we
might be tossing a billion dollars out
the window if it doesn't work
but the ones that do work we can already
start to roll out
vaccine programs like that's a really
smart idea if you've got money to burn
that's a great way to spend it because i
think at the end of the day
when you balance the economics uh lost
versus gained i think this will
likely side towards a net gain i'm not a
health
economics type of guy but i i'm pretty
sure that that's the way the
the tables will turn or at least the
whatever the word
you know what i'm trying to say no when
it starts to become available
it takes a while before we really get
towards being able to say
we have ended the pandemic right i mean
it's when you took
my belief my understanding is with
something as contagious as coronavirus
about 70
immunity is required for herd 40 percent
of the u.s
is not even interested in getting the
vaccine which is a totally different
story
but this once the vaccine rolls out it's
still going to be a while right
yeah yeah exactly i don't think this
pandemic's going to end with a bang but
more with a whimper right
it's probably going to peter out uh as
more and more people get vaccinated or
as more and more people
get this infection and then recover from
it and have some degree of immunity for
some period of time
so it's probably going to peter out i
think the other thing that
it's not talked about a lot is even
though
we'll have access to this vaccine in
many high-income countries
this pandemic is still going to be
raging in many other parts of the world
especially in low-income countries
that sadly are you know might not have
the same access to the vaccine that that
you and i will have
uh and uh and i think there's going to
be a lot of individuals
a significant proportion of the globe
that will be suffering
disproportionately suffering
because of limited access to the vaccine
because many of the high income
countries
are buying it all up and snatching it
all up and
and you know i really hope i know that
there are programs i know the who's
looking into this and there are groups
looking into this to really have more
equitable
vaccine programs worldwide
uh but you know part of me is a little
bit skeptical as to
how successful those will be oh we're
going to go to a break on the podcast
and radio show with dr isaac bogash but
our full conversation will be on the
youtube channel
last time you were on we talked at least
theoretically about reinfection
and over the last few days there has
been
what what i guess is being considered
the most specific report of a
re-infection with about four and a half
months in between
initial infection and a second infection
so far it seems the second infection is
asymptomatic which
raises a whole other series of questions
is my understanding more or less
accurate where is your belief now about
reinfection yeah this is really
interesting so
we knew this was going to happen it was
a matter of time we knew people were
going to start to get reinfected now
there were a couple of claims of
reinfection earlier on
but this case in hong kong is actually a
very credible claim they have the
genomic sequence
of the first infection they can show the
genomics weak
sequence of the second infection i mean
this is a very credible claim
uh and we're going to see more of this
for sure we're going to see more of this
i think what really
stands out with this case is that as you
point out this person was completely
asymptomatic the second time the only
reason he was picked up is because he
was traveling from spain back to
hong kong and there's screening tests
that are performed when you enter the
country they said whoa
you've got a positive case oh cool look
it's totally different from
the infection that you had before this
is a different
slightly different strain it has a
different genetic fingerprint of the of
the virus um
so you know it's hard to extrapolate
from one person to what it's going to
look like for the globe if people do
start to get re
i guess when people start to get
reinfected but you know what's nice to
know at least in this case is that this
person's immune system was doing exactly
what it should be doing
we know this person had symptoms with
his first infection was actually in
hospital with the first infection
and the second infection was completely
asymptomatic meaning
his immune system recognized the virus
uh was likely doing exactly what it was
supposed to be doing by fighting it off
the guy didn't even know he had an
infection
but did indeed test positive i think
what's
you know there's a lot of unanswered
questions one of them is to what extent
can people who
are reinfected transmit the virus to
other people
i think that's going to be a very
important question to answer but you
know i see this
if this is the case if people can get
reinfected but just have a much milder
course of illness
that's a huge win the reason the world
has is really stopped turning because of
this pandemic is because
so many people especially over the age
of 60 or those with underlying medical
conditions
can get sick and die now if people are
vaccinated and it reduces the
probability of that
if people um even if they get
re-infected after a vaccine
or sorry if they get infected after a
vaccine or if they get re-infected and
the second infection or the post-vaccine
infection is
mild we're okay we can start to slide
rapidly toward what we remember as
normal in the pre-covet 19 era
so if we can really mitigate the
morbidity
from this infection and of course the
mortality from this infection
i think that's a huge win a couple other
maybe more speculative things
there's been um i guess we could say
discussion of whether there might be
something
not that we would call an immunity but a
resistance
to coronavirus where uh
there there might just be it's not a
hundred percent of the population that
would easily contract it if exposed
it would be some number smaller than 100
percent and that that could potentially
be
factored into our progress towards
towards herd immunity
is that merely theoretical or is there
any reason to think that there's a
portion of
a human population of seven billion that
one disease or another
one virus or a bacteria that there may
be some resistance
to uh i think that's pretty theoretical
it wouldn't be the first time i mean
there certainly are
other infections where some people are
just more susceptible to getting it and
some people are more susceptible to
having a more severe outcome with it
and certainly it could certainly be the
case with
covid19 i think our understanding of
that concept
related to covet 19 is still pretty
rudimentary
and i think it would be very hard to
factor that into
models of herd immunity or models of how
this
uh pandemic will progress i just i don't
think we know enough about that to
really have
definitive statements yet last thing i
wanted to ask about
um therapeutics treatments rather than
vaccines
there have been so many different
studies done at this point
redesever dexamethasone
early later in the disease progress
convalescent plasma and monoclonal
antibodies
if you had to evaluate everything we
know now
under which sort of bucket do you think
the most effective treatments will fall
will they be under
the convalescent plasma antibody side
or will they be under the sort of
remdesseviere
avagan combinations of drugs side
i i gotta tell you full disclosure i
just don't know the therapeutics have
been
i think kind of disappointing yeah um
the best data we have i
personally i think the dexamethasone
data was the best data that that we have
and thankfully that you know cheap is
borscht and widely available
all over the world and most people who
practice hospital medicine have a lot of
experience using that drug because we
use it
all the time in the hospital for many
different reasons rem deserve your data
was
sort of okay for hospitalized people
that were sick enough to require
oxygen the newer rem deserver data that
looked at
individuals that weren't thick enough to
require oxygen was
i think rather disappointing does that
mean that the drug is a complete
write-off no absolutely not i think if
you have
access to it which is not reflective of
most of the world but if you have access
to it and you can use it early on in the
course of infection
in someone who's sick enough to require
oxygen i'd certainly i'd certainly use
it
but uh some of the earlier the the more
recent data with room device
remdezavir was a little disappointing um
the
same same with the convalescent plasma i
think uh
you know well it might have been touted
to be something huge listen we're going
to wait for the randomized
clinical trials to come out we don't
actually have that data yet
i'm completely open-minded i suspect it
will be meh
i suspect it will be come see at best it
might provide
some degree of help but i don't think
it's going to provide the degree of help
that we would want or that
i don't think it's going to be a game
changer um same with the monoclonals
maybe it'll be a little bit
more helpful i'm keeping my eye on
there's a class of drugs called the
interferons i'm very excited to see what
those look like
but in general i got to say seven months
in quite frankly i thought we'd be
further along
in the treatment on the treatment
strategies than where we are right now
there's been
mostly disappointments um and i think
the biggest win was the dexamethasone so
far but i think if you ask 10
infectious disease providers or 10
people that care for sick hospitalized
people with covet 19 you might get a few
different answers on that one
all right we've been speaking with dr
isaac bogosh who's an
infectious diseases physician and
scientist based out of the university of
toronto and toronto general hospital
always a pleasure having you on and i
really appreciate your time
my pleasure have a great day